(upbeat music)
- Nothing is more expensive than bad information.
Know the source, oneradionetwork.com.
- Well, a very pleasant good morning to you.
Oh, well, let's turn my microphone on.
Hold on a second.
(laughs)
I got a little control here
that we turn off during the weekend.
Yeah, it is.
Well, here we are.
Very pleasant good morning to you.
This is Patrick Timpone, oneradionetwork.com.
Hi, it is the 21st of December, quite a day.
The summer or the winter solstice, rather,
the longest day of the year.
Beginning tomorrow, the days will start to get longer.
This is pretty cool.
Some very interesting things
astrologically going on around this time.
You can look into the night sky tonight
around 7 p.m. Central, and you'll see the moon there.
And then if you go down to your right,
to your right, make a little catty corner,
to your right, you'll see that Jupiter and Saturn,
the two largest planets in the solar system,
will appear closer together
than they have ever been since the Middle Ages.
1226 is the last time they were this close together.
And a lot of the astrological people are saying
this is a really cool thing.
You have the Star of Bethlehem thing happening today,
and then also the summer solstice.
And this conjunction will take place
in the low western sky about an hour or so
after sunset, where you are, if you'd like to check it out.
1226.
I looked it up, King Henry III was the dude,
the main dude, back the last time that these guys were close
as close as they are today.
And a lot of the astrological people
that are looking at Corona,
the fight for Republic going on right now,
which is the hugest thing, in my opinion,
what has happened to this country since the Revolution,
as our Republic is kind of hanging by a thread,
and there's about one month to go
before the thread will break.
And the astrological people,
and a lot of the people that we're following,
our sources are saying,
just, you know, it's not over till the fat lady sings,
and she's very hoarse right now, the fat lady.
Okay, so we're honored to have Dr. Ray Peat on
as our last show for the year.
We're gonna be taking some time off
after this show, up until around the fifth,
when Atom Bergstrom will be here,
and we're gonna finish up our screenplay
and just rest up a little bit.
It's been quite a year for all of us
who have looked into the movie out there
we call "Physical Reality,"
and hard as we may try,
many of us got caught up in a little bit,
and that'll kind of wear you out.
So we can all use a little rest,
but we're gonna have all kinds of different
archive shows up here,
just a little bit of business
before we introduce you to Dr. Ray Peat,
who's one of our faves, very popular,
renowned nutritional counselor.
Been at it for a very long time,
it's about late 60s,
but we'll introduce you to Ray Peat in a minute,
just a little bit of business here.
We are totally phased out of Facebook.
We are going to be canceling that account
at the end of the year, in about two weeks.
We're moving over to Parler and MeWe,
and so if you'd like to connect with people of like minds,
MeWe's a good place to do it.
Just go to MeWe, Patrick Timpone.
You can connect up with people.
Just has to be friends with us,
or whatever they call it,
but it's public to everybody,
and then you can communicate with people.
And then we're doing some posting on Parler,
which is more like a Twitter thing,
where you just post different articles
and videos that we come across
from some of our sources,
and some insights,
but mostly the MeWe thing is more like Facebook,
and then we've gravitated off of YouTube,
so we won't be censored out there.
All of our videos are on One Radio Network.
Just go to One Radio Network,
click on videos,
and you'll see all the video shows there.
Not quite all of them yet,
but we'll be getting them all up in the next week or so.
So we're bypassing YouTube,
because they've been censoring us,
and Facebook, they're old news.
So there we are.
That's gonna be where we'll hit the ground running
in the first of the year,
and we're gonna have some very cool people
on the first of the year.
A doctor who has co-authored
a very landmark study on vaccines,
and showing that the kids who are unvaccinated
are healthier than the vaccinated kids.
He's going to be here next.
His name is Dr. Weiler.
Next, the first week in January.
Also, Martin Armstrong,
fellow we've been trying to get on for a very long time.
Fred Dashevsky in The Real World of Money.
Judy Mikovits is going to be here
in the beginning of January.
She's the one that came out with information about Fauci
and the whole AIDS pandemic.
And then Ralph Moss,
he is a PhD and the author of the book,
"Cancer, Incorporated," coming up in the first of the year.
So we have a lot of great things coming up.
Stay in touch with us through our website,
One Radio Network,
and then also through those social media places as well.
Dr. Ray Peat, as we said,
is here on the third Monday of every month.
Happy to have him here.
He's a PhD nutritional counselor,
and he worked on hormones
and really got his start there, specialization in hormones.
Wrote his dissertation in '72,
which he outlined the ideas on progesterone and hormones.
He's here on the third Monday of every month.
We're pleased to have him.
And one of his specialties is hormones as well.
Dr. Ray Peat, good morning.
Welcome back.
How are you, sir?
- Good morning.
Very good.
- Yeah, well, nice to have you here.
As you know, there are not a whole lot of people out there
talking about what could be going on
in the world of coronavirus, Dr. Peat,
other than just a few tidbits on Fox News,
where they kind of courted the idea
that the vaccines could be dangerous for just a few minutes.
And now we have Senator Rand Paul,
who's out big time questioning the whole idea
of the efficacy of the masks.
But when we talk about this,
one of the biggest things we get, Dr. Peat,
from people, people in my family and other people
who really watch mainstream TV,
is one of the biggest questions they say to us,
well, what about all these people?
What about all these deaths?
I mean, look at all these deaths.
How can you say that this thing
isn't what they are saying it is?
And I know you've been looking into that as well.
What can you help them with in that regard?
- I just read an article that was removed
from the website because of its dissent,
but a professor at Johns Hopkins, just a few weeks ago,
wrote an article looking at the pattern
of deaths in the US in 2020.
Genevieve Briand, I think her name is,
and it is saying what several of us have been saying
since last winter, that essentially nothing special
has been happening this year as far as deaths
and respiratory disease deaths go.
I looked at the total number of deaths recorded
from previous years and compared them to what the CDC
had done for each week of this year.
And they were remarkably historically low for months.
And it was only in the middle of the summer
when a few people had been saying
that it's very interesting that the spike of deaths
listed in the second week of April for COVID,
which was the exact week that the listed deaths
from influenza dropped sharply just within a day or two.
People stopped dying of influenza supposedly
when the surge of COVID deaths came.
But the quantity missing from all of those weeks
before April 12th were just about the same quantity
as the number of people in the spike.
Denis Rancourt had this graph on Del Bigtree's interview.
He said in the self that was enough to put
all of the top people in jail
because it's so obvious a fraud.
But when Genevieve Briand looks at these facts,
she notices that there was a historical fall off
in deaths from heart attacks, strokes,
and a couple of the other standard invariable deaths
that corresponded to the spike.
So what they seem to have done is just
change the definition of people dying
of heart attacks and strokes.
The order went out to, by default,
if you didn't know what a person died of,
for example, someone fell off a roof
and went in and died and was put in a hospital.
Put down as a COVID death.
People with cancer were put down as COVID deaths.
And nurses photographed the hospital record
showing that people who tested negative
repeatedly were put down as COVID deaths.
And at the same time,
Jon Rappoport has done a good article on this.
At the same time, they ordered people to run
the PCR test beyond its capacity of accuracy,
and far into the range in which it produces false positives.
So they ordered people to expand the testing program
using a method that is predicted
and known to produce false positives.
So they were getting people who weren't infected
very, almost certainly, these false positives
were being put down as having the COVID infection.
And then whatever they died of,
they were recorded as COVID deaths.
So I'm just as skeptical as I was in February or March.
- Even probably more so.
The New York Times is out this morning, Dr. Peat.
And I mean, it's just like a tragic finish.
And they have a graph of the new cases
in the United States is per million is way, way above.
Japan seems to be the lowest.
And of course, these new cases, as they're said in the news,
are based on the PCR test.
Some people are suggesting, Dr. Bhakdi,
we had on, Sucharit Bhakdi and others,
that the PCR could be as much as 95% inaccurate.
You think that's possible?
- Yeah, it's designed to run a maximum of 33 to 35 cycles.
And Fauci ordered it to run more than 40 cycles.
That's just like jiggling the machine
so it puts out some kind of output,
even though it has nothing to do with reality.
- And there was a tape that we ran on our show.
I don't have it right here, but this was in, I think, July,
where he was on tape doing an interview
and suggested that anything over 30,
he said possibly 35, but anything over 30 cycles,
the CT is just showing up dead,
I think it's dead nucleotides or dead molecules,
whatever his term was.
- Yeah, nucleic acids.
- Nucleic acids.
You've been at this a long time.
Is it surprising?
I mean, your opinion of how this thing has managed
to go where it goes has gone and still going today.
- Yeah, and at the first sign of possible
flu-like epidemic or pandemic,
Schwab, the founder of the World Economic Forum,
said this is better than planetary warming.
This is just what we need to bring things under control,
to destroy the legacy economies,
to shift over to artificial intelligence everywhere,
telemedicine, remote education, remote shopping, and so on.
Get rid of all retail stores, retail schools,
retail hospitals and medical practices.
- And many are saying, too,
we've had quite a few shows, Dr. Peat,
on the idea that the whole financial system
wants to, the term being used is reset, right?
And they're using this for that, too,
and nobody really knows what that means,
but I'm sure there's a lot of digital stuff in our future.
- Dollars will be outlawed as physical objects.
- You think so?
You think that'll be it? - Silver or gold.
And you'll have only digital money,
and at that point, the banks will start copying Japan
and charging interest for you
to store your money in the bank.
So having savings will be making money for the banks,
and your money will be shrinking constantly.
- Yeah, not keeping up with the inflation,
which is, of course, the expansion of the monetary supply,
right, when they print money.
- They won't even have to count on puffing up
the money supply to shrink everyone's money.
They can just put it down on the account
as the cost of storing your money.
- Yeah, right.
Lots of talk, too, about these new digital coins,
like the FedCoin and the ECB's gonna do one,
and they want people to get an app, to have an app,
and then they'll be able to just give you digits
when you need them, you know.
Well, before we start taking questions,
let's move on to the vaccine.
They've been released, of course, Pfizer.
Quite a few reports that people are not reporting on,
but there's been, I think, 13,000,
really, what they claim are—
how do they term—how do they use the term?—
significant events with people, you know,
that have taken the vaccine, according to news reports.
- I saw that-- - Did you see that?
- There'd been three or four cases of Bell's palsy,
and the FDA said, well, that probably would've happened
anyway, even though there were three in the vaccinated people
and one in the placebo, but even if it's causing that,
we have drugs to treat that.
So, according to the FDA,
a few minor things, like the paralysis,
as long as they have some drug to stop the pain,
it's okay with them.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, Sucharit Bhakdi, who was on the show,
talked about the dangers of these vaccines,
and his opinion, he's got quite a prominent
immunologist and biologist, and he was suggesting
that the idea of genetic insertion,
this RNA, DNA thing, is totally new
and has never been done.
Can you explain to us more clearly about what this means,
what's really going into these things?
Have you looked into that?
- Yeah, have you ever heard of the reverse transcriptase
enzyme in 1969?
- No.
- I was in graduate school, and at that time,
professors were actually talking about
the central dogma of molecular biology,
which is that information flows only from the DNA gene
through RNA into protein.
Information can never go the other way,
from protein to RNA, or from RNA to DNA.
If it went that direction, that would be Lamarckism,
so absolutely, that's unthinkable.
- What's the word that would be, what, sir, Lamarckism?
- Lamarckism?
- What does that mean?
- Oh, the non-belief in evolution,
or evolution by intention, becoming what you intend to be,
not what random changes impose on you.
Absolute Darwinism is that everything happens
by meaningless chance.
- Oh, like it's just a random thing,
but you kind of believe, if I understand your writings,
it's not that way, that we are more creating as we go,
correct?
- Right, right.
So in 1969, when Temin and Baltimore discovered
that there was a retrovirus on the order
of what later turned out to be the HIV/AIDS thing,
they found that this retrovirus consisted of RNA,
and that it had with it an enzyme that could copy its RNA
into DNA and deposit that DNA in our genes,
and then our own enzymes would forever make copies
of the virus.
So in that case, information was flowing from RNA to DNA,
and so none of my professors could accept
that that was possible.
- Possible, yeah.
- Even though I think they got the Nobel Prize
for the discovery.
But now it turns out that, again, the professors hate
to even think about this, but it turns out
that we have our intrinsic enzymes that will turn RNA
to DNA, exactly what Lamarckism would say we needed
if we're going to adapt to the world
and become what we intend to be.
These physical adaptations that we make can be recorded
in the genes if we have reverse transcriptase enzymes
to turn RNA into DNA.
- Oh, so let me stop you for a second.
So if I understand then, as soul spiritual beings
in these bodies because of our state of consciousness
and lifestyle, we mainly affect the RNA and not the DNA,
but it's shown that the RNA can work backwards,
not like you were taught, and that's why epigenetics works.
- Yeah, yeah. - Is that close?
- Yeah, that's why the whole idea of epigenetics,
first it was impossible, then it was only an event
that was temporary in the cytoplasm for the moment,
then, well, maybe it was passed on to your offspring
and then maybe four generations and so on.
So the whole idea of epigenetics has taken about 50 years
to get established halfway.
- Yeah, yeah, and so when we come into this reality,
do our DNA and RNA carry different things
that may be from grandma and grandpa and stuff?
- Oh, they're probably working on it.
Definitely we carry the experiences back to probably
our great-grandparents in animal experiments.
You can see it for four or five generations consistently,
how well they ate, for example.
- Yes, but so just because great-grandpa, though,
had a heart issue, it doesn't mean we have to,
as many of the doctors believe,
just simply by changing our lifestyle and we just--
- Yeah, good experiences you have
will erase the bad experiences.
- How does that work?
Good experiences, that's interesting,
erase the bad experiences.
- The injury that happened to your grandparents,
for example, will cause changes in their hormones
and their hormones will affect their reproductive cells.
And this incidentally brings in the exosome
virus-like particle thing, Darwin called them gemmules,
in which the changes that happen epigenetically
in our body cells are floating around in the body,
getting into our germ cells.
But anyway, empirically what we've seen demonstrated
in the last 40 years is that changes do happen,
at least in the hormones, if not in the exosomes.
But the hormonal changes cause the germ cells
to be a little different.
And then the fertilization of these
slightly altered germ cells,
the organism is implanted in the uterus
and the mother's hormonal and metabolic constitution
is shaping the organism all during
its nine months of development.
And so her inherited from her parents,
her metabolic abilities are influencing
the developmental metabolic abilities of the offspring.
So it's all on the level of fluids and hormones
and things that have been known for over 100 years.
These are very obviously going to affect
how the pregnancy turns out.
And so that means that you can intervene in the pregnancy,
make the pregnancy happier and healthier.
And of all things, don't shock the immune system
of the pregnant woman.
But CDC advocates giving flu vaccine, for example,
to pregnant women, a murderously insane idea.
Any kind of immunological shock increases
autism risk, for example.
- Interesting.
So these exosomes you talked about,
they have been spoken about by people
around the world since this whole thing started.
And they were saying that they were identifying a virus
that looks just like these exosomes.
Can you explain that a little bit
and what's going on there?
Is that true?
- All of them look a little bit different.
So you can't say they look exactly like them.
But the particles, the exosomes are roughly
a tenth of a micron,
about more or less the size of a flu or COVID virus
or thousands of other types of viruses.
So in terms of size and the fact that as a rule,
not always they'll have some RNA,
maybe a little bit of DNA in them,
and proteins, hormones.
Material, generally our exosomes are carrying information
from a sick cell to a bone marrow cell, for example,
signaling the need for some repair material,
some cells to be manufactured to replace injured cells.
So the bone marrow differentiates
in the direction of the information
it got from the injured cells' exosomes
and puts out cells which know how to migrate
to the area that was injured,
the lung or the kidney or wherever.
- Interesting.
- It sends in repair cells.
- Wow.
- And the repair cells,
it happens that cancer is always sending out signals
for help to repair the wound.
And they found that even when they cut out the cancer
or poison it out or irradiate it out,
the wound area still, or even more so,
sends out alarm signals that it needs repair cells.
So somewhere else in the body, like the bone marrow,
produces repair cells which migrate in.
But now the wound site has been horribly injured,
new kinds of inflammation,
creating problems for the tumor-removed area.
So the new cells arriving there
experience even worse conditions
than the removed cells did.
So it means that whenever you destroy a cancer,
you haven't destroyed the conditions in that area.
So that area is very likely to produce new cancers.
- Yes, so that's why we see the numbers.
And oftentimes people who do nothing, no chemo,
do even better than folks that do that.
Is that the argument you've just made?
- Yeah, and there's very few studies
that have looked at the people
who chose not to have any therapy,
found that they lived much longer
than the people who immediately went
to have the cancer removed.
- Fascinating.
So do we then share, if these exosomes are information
on how to, are they actually information
to help us all evolve?
And do we share these exosomes?
- That has been theorized as the only plausible source
of where viruses could come from.
Because a virus lives only in a higher organism.
So definitely viruses didn't evolve
as an independent pest.
They had to come from a higher organism.
So now that we know that higher organisms
create their own virus-like particles,
it's only plausible to assume
that viruses are derived from these normal exosomes.
But that if a very sick animal
is spreading its particles around,
and another organism,
remotely related organism,
picks up these sick particles,
then its organism, if it isn't in very good health itself,
these sick particles might further derange
the cells of a sick organism.
So the whole idea is plausible
that exosomes from sick animals
can make other animals sick.
- Yeah, and that would be,
maybe, oh, I just flashed on the idea, Dr. Peat.
Maybe that's why many animals go off on their own to die.
Maybe they--
- Yeah, I think that is kind of intuitive, native knowledge.
- Just to save the tribe, huh?
No sense.
So this corona thing, I mean,
it's just a coronavirus that's been around.
And to your opinion, do you think it's any different or,
I still don't understand where it came from.
And it's just gonna keep going.
I mean, you don't kill something like this, right?
A virus just, explain it.
- The coronavirus type is very common,
and people have been dying from it for who knows how long.
A really bad cold in a person who is otherwise weak or sick,
a really bad cold has been killing people forever
just because it causes inflammation
that their body can't deal with.
- Can't deal with, right.
- But I think there has been a lot of research
and there has been some political maneuvering
connected with the military research,
germ warfare research that Richard Nixon
supposedly terminated in 1969.
Those labs which had been devoted to creating viruses
and bacteria that were especially lethal,
they were told to stop producing biological weapons.
But immediately almost, they went to producing
the same organisms but saying, we need to do this
because enemies might do it,
and we need to create defenses.
So we have to invent any horrible thing
that someone else might invent as a weapon.
So that, for example, we can test vaccines against it.
So there was no end to the military germ warfare.
They just renamed it as vaccine research.
And one of our major vaccine research labs
continuing this military biological warfare research
was Ralph Baric's group
at the University of North Carolina.
And under his name in PubMed,
you can find several articles describing
the manufacture of viruses of this type
and how they picked out a lethal part
from another virus such as the spike protein
which binds to and inactivates our angiotensin receptor.
Angiotensin 1,
I'm not sure that the numbers are so many subdivisions,
but anyway, it binds to our defensive angiotensin receptor.
And it's a degrading enzyme.
And the activation of inflammation in the body,
activating the angiotensin system
by knocking out the enzyme
that degrades the inflammatory enzyme,
that is the chosen mechanism
not only for the natural virus,
but chosen because it is such a destructive,
dangerous feature of a virus.
So it was picked out in the Baric lab
as a feature to put into their synthetic virus.
And other particular nucleotides in the RNA chain
were manipulated.
One or two nucleotide changes at a time
to improve the ability of the virus to infect human cells.
Last I saw these articles were still up on the internet.
So there was no question that a virus of this type
had been a project for years.
And then a few years ago,
the CDC closed down the Fort Detrick,
the main famous germ warfare lab,
because they had had over 1,000 accidents.
And it was in the news that they were closing the lab
because of its lack of clean behavior,
exposing the environment to their toxic viruses.
That was in the newspaper.
And for them to be so public as well as so sloppy,
I think was a propaganda operation
to convince the Chinese who had no doubt
about all of the stuff which had been in the news
for 40 years that the US was working on biological warfare.
So with all of this publicity coming out in recent years,
obviously the Chinese would be very sensitive
to taking instant precautions of an exaggerated sort
if they thought the Americans were actually spilling
this horribly lethal virus
and that it might get spilled into China.
So I think it was propaganda intended to get the Chinese
to put out a historically huge reaction to a virus
which they got under control in a few weeks.
But having that as an example in the news
that China shut down the whole country,
then that news they had created with this publicity
over preceding two or three years,
that was the example for realizing the plans
of the World Economic Forum which had been talked about
and planned for like Event 201.
- Yes.
- They were planning for this
and so they created the international staged theatrical
defensive reaction of China and said,
"Look what they did, we have to do the same."
So even without any evidence of actually how many people
were dying from it and actually how infective it was,
just what China reported, the whole thing came into play.
The program that had been designed years previously
and now everyone was trained to put it into practice.
Lockdowns, the whole campaign to sell vaccines
to everyone in the world.
- Fascinating, interesting story.
Dr. Ray Peat, Patrick Timpone, OneRadioNetwork.com.
So before we go to the calls,
and we'll take a quick break before the calls,
but by the way, if you'd like to ask Dr. Peat a question,
he doesn't do medical advice, we can't do a lot here,
but at least he can maybe lead you in the right direction,
save you some time on some issue that you're having.
We have a lot of good questions already,
we'll get to as many as we can.
But back to the vaccine and this idea
that that's actually putting genetic material
in which many are arguing
that it's never really been done before.
I mean, what risk could this pose for people
that are taking this vaccine?
- Oh, you asked me that?
- Yes, sir.
- Yeah, it's the shock to the system
is the first thing.
Two nurses in England who on the first day
developed anaphylaxis,
they had a history of allergies,
but Pfizer or whoever their vaccine was made by
didn't announce to the world
that people who had allergies shouldn't take it.
They had excluded allergic people from their test subjects.
So naturally, there was absolutely no evidence of safety.
If they excluded allergic people and old people,
and who knows how many other categories
were excluded from the test samples,
that that was an obligatory bit of information
that should have been announced to the world last Monday
when the vaccine was announced as a finished thing.
But they said, "Well, yes, we did exclude allergic people."
And immediately an official in the FDA said,
"But there are 1.6 million profoundly allergic people
"in the United States.
"That's a very large number.
"We can't exclude that many from receiving the vaccine."
So according to the FDA,
the Pfizer policy of not testing it on allergic people
and then giving it to people with a history of allergy
was perfectly all right,
because that was an appropriate risk.
Safety testing has never been done like that.
It's really fraudulent.
And the article was published
in the New England Journal of Medicine.
People have analyzed it,
showing that the article didn't resemble at all
the way an announcement of a new drug or product
should be handled.
It was like a public relations advertising bit.
And it went with an editorial,
not by an expert who could evaluate the Pfizer report,
but the editorial was written by the editor-in-chief
of New England Journal of Medicine,
whose magazine receives advertising money
and major support from Pfizer.
And this editor was on the FDA committee
voting to approve it.
So there was sort of a conspiracy all the way
from advertising money
through the medical journal announcement
and the approval of it in the FDA.
And then the FDA is saying it's all right,
no matter what it does to people.
- Is there a potential then for long-term effects,
two, three, five, 10 years from now
that we would have no idea of knowing?
- Yeah, not only the damage done to the immune system,
which has its repercussions,
depending on how basic the injury was,
but being RNA and even our own DNA replicating enzymes,
what we need for every cell to reproduce
and to produce offspring.
The DNA replicase enzyme happens to have the ability
to function as a reverse transcriptase,
able to transcribe RNA into DNA,
making basically genes out of this bit of viral RNA,
which can go into the genes.
The person can then become a factory
for making the spike protein,
this uniquely inflammation-promoting bit of information,
producing the viral protein,
multiplying it endlessly by possibly all of our cells.
So we would not only produce increasing amounts
as our body went through its normal,
restoration and growth processes,
but being spreadable by our secretions
and passed on to our offspring
if people should live that long.
- And so there could be then some validity to the idea
that some are concerned about the potential issue
of making women less fertile with this thing
if they figured it out right.
- Yeah, that particular thing was based on the similarity
between an enzyme in the vaccine
and the enzyme which creates the placenta,
happens to be just a structurally similar protein.
That created doubt and suspicions
that any sensible person would want to check it out.
But instead of checking it out,
they called it a conspiracy theory and so on.
- So it's not a big stretch if folks explore the idea
of eugenics and some very bad people
that think there's too many people on the planet.
It's not a huge stretch to say
that this vaccine is part of that.
- Yeah, you shouldn't even have to be a suspicious person
to want to check out all of the possible things
that could possibly eliminate the species
or a big part of it.
- You know, in vaccines, there's this idea of shedding
where the kids that get vaccinated
actually can be more dangerous than the unvaccinated
'cause they throw off stuff.
Could it be possible that the vaccinated people for corona
could throw off stuff that you and I
wouldn't want to be exposed to?
- Yeah, because that RNA is put in there to be copied.
- Oh, great.
So those should be the ones with the dangerous passports
and not the non-vax people.
- Right.
- But now before we go though, this is key.
So I want to get your take.
You know, there's people like Cowan, Kaufman,
David Parker, others who suggested the virus idea.
You know, the germ theory is structurally incoherent
because they have proven that you can take snot
and saliva from somebody with something
and give it to another person, right?
And it doesn't work.
It only works in the Petri dish.
- No, if you take it out of a Petri dish
where you have a big concentration
and drip it into someone's nose while they're lying down,
it's a pretty repeatable process.
- But not necessarily person to person.
- No, it's pretty hard to spread a cold
from person to person.
But the fact that you can do it,
I don't think you should go around saying
that the whole idea doesn't work.
If you've ever seen a cold sore
passed on in a family,
you know that viruses are real.
- Right, a cold sore is always,
but you can touch it, you know, like a herpes virus
and you have, and so viruses are real.
They're there.
But when you say it's difficult to even share
a cold or a flu virus.
- Yeah, they've put one very sick person
with a cold into a room to play cards
for several hours, passing things back and forth
with a bunch of healthy people.
And that almost never goes across.
You have to be receptive.
So the terrain theory is the basic thing.
But you can't forget that things like herpes virus
are super easy to transmit.
With just the slightest break in the skin, for example,
doesn't even have to be a visible wound.
- So then that would play as well as for STDs?
- For which?
- STDs, sexually transmitted diseases.
- Oh, oh, sure.
Same thing 'cause you're actually making contact?
- Yeah, and--
- To the mucosa, right?
- Yeah, Epstein-Barr and lots of contact viruses.
The experiments show that with extreme effort,
putting a concentrated batch of viruses
derived from one person,
if you put 'em right into the upper nasal membrane,
it will catch on a fair amount of the time.
- It'll catch on a fair amount of the time,
but passing stuff to somebody who's two feet away from you,
are you saying it's pretty rare?
- Yeah, in one experiment,
they put a dye in a person's runny nose.
- They put a what?
- A colored agent into their nose.
- Okay.
- And then had them play cards.
And the dye was transmitted to everyone in the card game,
but no one caught the virus.
- No one caught it.
So then that brings us back to social distancing
and all that and lockdowns and masking.
There's real no science behind any of it, is there?
- Absolutely no science.
- Wow, wow, man.
- Giving vitamin D is probably the single
most functional thing.
Vitamin D, vitamin A,
adequate protein and carbohydrate and everything,
but vitamin D is probably the main deficiency
leading to epidemics.
- So are you a fan then,
if folks can't get sun on their skin,
to take supplemental D during the time
when they can't get sun?
- Oh, definitely.
That has, in the higher latitudes,
the winter sun doesn't make any vitamin D to count.
And we need probably 5,000 international units a day
is good for adults.
If a person is overweight, it might take more than that.
But the idea, the so-called research done medically
has used doses of things like 500 milligrams,
500 units instead of 5,000 units.
And then they say, oh, vitamin D didn't do anything
to strengthen their bones or improve their immunity
or reduce inflammation.
But you have to actually get their serum of vitamin D up,
and it has to be the kind of vitamin D
that's the same as made in your skin by the sunlight
and developed in your liver.
And not the 1,25-dihydroxycholecalciferol,
which is called--
- That they test for, right?
That's what they test for?
- They've activated the vitamin D,
is what they call that one.
But we only activate ordinary vitamin D
into the dihydroxycholecalciferol under stress.
If we're deficient in vitamin D,
the curative anti-inflammatory material,
our body suddenly starts converting this,
any trace of it, to a very small amount
of 1,25-dihydroxy, and that happens
to do all kinds of destructive calcification things.
So if you hear about the toxic vitamin A,
it's almost always because they're talking
about active vitamin A.
But if you take enough calcium in your diet
and the normal amount of sunlight exposure
or vitamin D from even fish oil
is usually an adequate source,
if you take calcium and that kind
of environmentally derived vitamin D,
you'll have extremely low activated vitamin D.
Activated vitamin D is the dangerous one.
- And is that the one that shows up on a test
when you test for vitamin D?
- Only if the doctor does the wrong thing.
If he's a kidney expert, he's likely to do the wrong thing.
- Okay, but generally, the one that they test
for the vitamin D is okay.
- Yeah, it's called 25-hydroxy.
- 25-hydroxy.
You mentioned the sun, so like here in Texas,
if I get out in the sun, I'm at an altitude
where I'm getting D in December?
- Yeah, in the winter, the summer,
the sun is a little weaker, but in Texas--
- We still get it.
- Yeah, in a couple of hours,
you're getting a moderate dose of vitamin D.
- In what areas would our listeners not get
the vitamin D on their skin in December, that they won't?
- For example, at the latitude of Oregon.
Even San Francisco, I think the sun is so weak right now
that you could sit in it for eight hours.
- You still don't get it, huh?
Is there any risk of having too much
of the supplemental vitamin D, getting too much?
Are there any side effects?
- In experiments, either by accident
or in animal experiments, people have occasionally,
for confusion, taken maybe a quarter of a million
units per day and doing that for a matter of weeks.
They do start showing signs of calcification,
but if they stop in time,
it isn't the extreme danger that it was made out to be
when they insisted that 200 units a day
was okay for kids and 400 for adults.
- But now 5,000 units, if somebody's taking 10 or 20,
probably no issues with that if they wanted to take--
- Yeah, I've known quite a few people
who weren't getting their blood level up
on 5,000 or 6,000 units a day,
so they took, for just a couple of weeks,
they would take 10 or 20,000 units
and suddenly their blood level would come up to normal
and their symptoms would generally just suddenly disappear.
Weakness, body pains, depression,
rheumatoid symptoms just respond amazingly
when you actually get your 25-hydroxy level
up in your bloodstream.
- And if you had a number that folks could look for,
what would that be on that 25-hydroxy on the blood test?
- On the nanogram scale, it's about 50 nanograms per milliliter.
- Yeah, that's the main thing they use.
So that's the D.
If folks need to make sure they're getting A,
you're okay with some high-quality fish oil?
- Not fish oil, but liver oil.
- Oh, now what's the difference?
Do you mean cod liver oil?
- Yeah, cod liver or halibut liver oil
is you get lots of vitamin D and A
in a small amount of oil,
but in fish oil, you get only the tiniest trace of vitamins.
Just it accidentally gets in there
when the whole fish is squashed.
- Could you take a good high-quality cod liver oil
ongoing without any ill effects with the yellow fat
and all the lipofuscin and stuff?
- I don't advocate it,
but if it's your only source of vitamin D and A,
naturally, it'll save your life,
but still, it's better not to have the chronic--
- Too much, yeah, too much.
Well, and the foods with the D and A?
- Oh, liver.
- Liver?
- Any chicken liver, beef, any kind of liver,
is a great source of not only A and D,
also K, all of the nutrients.
The only problem with liver is it's very high in iron
and very high in phosphate,
and so I don't think you should eat
more than one good serving of liver per week
because you can chronically overload
on some of the over-concentrated nutrients.
- And we've been told that many of us
have too much iron running around anyway
because they put it in the food and--
- Yeah. - Is that right?
- But yeah, one serving of iron per week
won't hurt you unless you're eating
red meat twice a day or something.
- Yeah, yeah, and you talk of serving
to be four to six ounces, something like that,
would we do you up?
- Yeah, four ounces is a pretty filling amount of liver.
- Yeah, it is.
Well, stay right there, sir.
Boy, this has been a great first time.
We may wanna keep you,
can we keep you just a little bit longer today?
Is that okay? - Oh, sure.
- Oh, good, because we have lots of emails
and our first part has already been an hour or so.
We'll impose upon the good doctor for a bit.
We're pretty excited about a sale that's going on
today only on Surthrival, 21%
in observance of the summer,
the winter solstice, December 21.
Today only, today only, 21% site-wide,
everything on Surthrival.
So jump on it if you wanna get some products.
Use promo code infinite, I-N-F-I-N-I-T-E.
So that's everything, everything they have.
Let's do the pine pollen first.
We're talking with Daniel Vitalis of Surthrival.
Is there a benefit to using the elk velvet antler
and the pine pollen together?
- Yeah, they really enhance each other's effect
and they don't have any contraindications.
So both of them nourish and feed anabolic pathways,
but in different ways.
The pine pollen adds direct testosterone
and other anabolic hormones into the body.
The elk antler helps to fine tune the metabolism
and feeds in all that connective tissue enhancing collagen
that helps to feed and build up the body.
At the same time, it helps to increase lean body mass.
The two together would be your optimal nature-based formula
for both bodybuilding, for youthening, for anti-aging,
and for anybody who's looking to keep their body
in a youthful, anabolic, vigorous, and elastic state.
- And is it fair to say they're both tonics
so they can be used every day?
- Yeah, both pine pollen and elk antler are tonic medicines.
In other words, they don't have any contraindications
of use and they don't have to be cycled on and off.
So somebody could use them short-term,
but they could also use them long-term
without worrying that they're overdosing themselves on them
because like you said, they're tonic medicines.
- Every day in every way, let's just get stronger.
Boys and girls, all so--
Yeah, you bet 'em.
Boy, this would be a great time
if you'd like to try the pine pollen.
I just ran downstairs to get some water.
You'd like to get some pine pollen, and I ran.
It's a great time to do it.
Promo code infinite, today only, the 21st of December.
25, 21%.
And then you might want to try
their vitamin D K3 product.
So we have like right at 5,000 units per serving,
non-GMO manufactured with the extreme care.
Look at the, listen to the ingredients.
See if I can find them here.
The D3 from lanolin, K2 is from natto,
which is a traditional Japanese fermented food.
And that's it.
So you got the vitamin D K3, K2 or K3,
what do they call it?
Vitamin D K2 Daylight.
And it's only 29 bucks, and you get a nice supply,
and you can buy a couple bottles and get 21% off today
with promo code infinite.
Pretty cool, huh?
Have you heard about hydrogen?
If you're thinking about,
well, check this out for an investment.
Hydrogen technology is pretty exciting.
This is George.
Many people have said, and we concur,
that the number one investment we should make
is in our health.
Here's George Wiseman.
- Last caller, I'm sorry, I didn't remember his name,
said an investment.
And this is really the investment kind of thing
that you need to do.
Not my machine specifically.
I think I sell the world's best machine,
and I do my best to maintain it
and support the customers and everything.
But regardless of who you get it from,
you really should invest in your health.
How are you gonna enjoy life if you haven't got health?
How are you gonna fulfill that bucket list?
So number one on the bucket list should be your health,
and then you get some extra years.
I say this thing not only adds years to your life,
because the science is showing a 30 to 50% life extension.
So I'm expecting to go to the 120, 150 years old,
and I'd help a lot of people between now and then.
But it also adds life to your years.
There's no sense living your last decade of life
if you're in a hospital bed attached to machines,
you know what I mean?
Throwing a Frisbee and having fun.
- It's so true, isn't it?
Boy, if we don't feel good and have the energy
to do what we need to do, I mean, what's the point?
And here's an investment with a lifetime warranty,
and also a one year, no questions asked, money back,
guarantee if you don't want it.
Check out this AquaCure machine,
bubbling hydrogen gas, drinking it, breathing it.
This is real cutting-edge technology.
Check it out in our store.
Use promo code OneRadio for a 10% discount.
The AquaCure Brown's Gas Machine on OneRadioNetwork.com.
And if you're clever and you figure out
how to write it off on your taxes,
which got a good tax person, they could figure it out.
I don't, trust me, I don't do tax advice,
but you can get one before the end of the year,
and just kind of get one.
These are great.
Use promo code OneRadio.
You can go to MolecularHydrogenInstitute.com
and look at peer-reviewed studies from around the world.
Lots going on in China, Japan,
with all kinds of pretty interesting stories
with helping people to recover from strokes,
breathing the hydrogen.
Our machine is Brown's gas,
which is just a step up from just pure hydrogen.
Check it out, OneRadioNetwork.com.
(upbeat music)
- We are listener supported, One Radio Network.
- Well, we've had quite a first hour with Dr. Ray Peat.
Thanks for being here, sir.
Ray Peat, it is DrPeat.com.
You can do Dr. Peat's newsletter,
DrPeatsNewsletter@gmail.com, right?
And get your newsletter?
- Right.
- That's good.
And you put that out every couple of months, huh?
- Two months, yeah.
- Every two months.
Well, let's get to some emails for you, Doc.
So here's one.
So kissing someone vaccinated with an RNA virus
can spread the exosomes from the vaccine
by horizontal genetics?
(laughs)
That's great.
- I think that's a real possibility.
- Wow, man.
So now we'll be on dating sites and say,
instead of wanting people who have been vaccinated, right?
To get people that haven't been vaccinated.
- Yeah.
- That's great, man.
Only on planet Earth, Doc.
How about, would you please ask Dr. Peat,
is the table sugar processed with phosphoric acid
for refinement better than the one processed with sulfur?
Hmm.
- What kind of sugars?
- The table sugar.
Table sugar processed with phosphoric acid
for refinement better than the one processed with sulfur.
- Sulfur is a much more allergenic material
that in trace amounts has the ability
to cause allergic reactions.
And trace amounts of phosphoric acid
are almost always harmless.
Down at the threshold where you can't taste them,
sulfur has the risk of increasing allergies.
- Okay.
Thank you for asking Dr. Peat on your show.
I have a question for him.
What is the significance of the optic nerve cup-
to-disc ratio, C/D ratio,
and can it be brought back into normal?
Diagnosis of glaucoma.
- The word is cuff?
- I'm sorry?
- C-U-F-F was the word?
- What is the significance of the optic nerve cup?
Cup, C-U-P.
- Oh, cup, cup.
I think cup represents dead tissue that has atrophied.
And so it determines or expresses
how much of the nerve is gone.
So I would guess that the cup is a bad indicator.
- Do you have any suggestions?
We get so many emails with folks
that are beginning to get cataracts over the years.
It's a pretty, very popular kind of a challenge.
What do you think about it,
the cause and some things people can do?
We're talking about the eyes here.
- By putting an animal lens with a cataract
into a culture dish,
they have found that it's responsive
to the osmolarity of the solution,
that a watery solution expands a cataract
and a slightly over-concentrated solution
can regress a cataract.
And inflammation generally creates a watery,
low osmolarity solution that contributes.
The cataract itself becomes opaque
because the cells take up more water than normal.
And in that process,
they are losing not only their transparency,
but their resilience.
The proteins in the cell are like egg white.
When it's cooked, it's opaque and firm.
When it's functional and alive and clear,
the water is in a special state.
Things that damage the cells—ultraviolet light
or too much estrogen, for example,
are things that will change the state of water in the cell,
make it over-hydrated, hardened, and opaque.
Keeping systemic inflammation low,
avoiding the things that tend to waterlog your tissues,
all of those reduce the progress of cataracts.
And incidentally, lots and lots of optometrists
are now exaggerating the language; they're telling people
that they have developing cataracts
when what they're really seeing
is just the normal yellowing and browning
of the lens with aging.
An old yellowed or browned lens can still be very clear.
It's not a cataract.
It's just the change of color with aging.
A cataract is a more or less focal spot
where the cells turn white and become opaque
as they take up too much water in the wrong arrangement.
- Interesting, wow.
Linda's in Michigan.
Dear Patrick, I looked for you on MeWe, couldn't find you.
Just do Patrick Timpone on MeWe and you'll find us.
Could you please ask Dr. Peat if he would think,
what could, oh, a pillow that's infused with silver,
could that be a beneficial effect on protecting from EMFs?
Wow.
- Doing what with silver?
- A silver infused pillow.
- Oh, no, I think the conductor has to be between you
and the source of the EMF.
- I think so too.
- So you can get curtains with embedded wire filaments,
silver or copper or whatever.
And if you have a telephone tower visible
through your window and you put a big drape over the window
and maybe over any of the wall between you and the tower,
that is protective.
- David is in Atlanta, Georgia listening this morning
or watching, whatever.
Dr. Peat, you've said that metabolism
and epigenetic damage causes baldness.
My metabolism has improved but I'm still bald.
So how can I undo the epigenetic damage and grow some hair?
- The tissue, once it's damaged, has changed its structure
and laid down a lot of collagen and fibrous cells
and so the examples of people who have gone
from complete baldness to regrowing a good crop of hair,
it has usually involved some kind of shock to the tissue
that activates repair processes that will actively clean out
some of the fibrous tissue.
Probably massage would be the best bet
to activate the cells.
Like putting a niacin or something
that simply causes a local inflammation.
Not niacinamide but the one that makes the skin turn red.
That sort of thing creating a mild inflammation.
One old guy fell on his head in the fireplace
and seriously burned his scalp and that area,
when it healed, was producing hair.
So it takes some kind of activation,
getting circulation back into it
to actively remove the fibrous tissue
and let the germ cells or the stem cells
that make hair recover.
An important part of that is to make sure
that your parathyroid hormone is down
at the lower end of the normal range
because you're getting enough calcium
and vitamin D in your diet and not too much phosphate.
Eating a lot of meat, the phosphate is constantly
pushing up your parathyroid hormone
and the parathyroid hormone is turning down metabolism
in your hair follicle.
- Oh I see.
So but just to the original,
there's actually some physical issues going on
with the bald guys so the hair can't even pop out.
You said there could be different ways to scrub it
or I don't know.
- Yeah, effectively rubbing it every day.
- Rubbing it every day.
That's right, that might work.
That's pretty interesting.
Okay, here's one, Sophie, she's in Jacksonville, Florida.
Dr. Peat, what are your thoughts on cactus fruit
like prickly pear and dragon fruit?
Some research says that they have
high calcium to phosphate ratio.
- The main thing is they're delicious foods
and growing in the desert,
they do tend to have lots of minerals.
In some of the traditional areas of Mexico,
they cook down the prickly pear fruit,
make a mush of it and then concentrate it
and it's one of the most delicious candies
I've ever tasted.
- Is that right?
- It's just full of minerals, calcium and magnesium
in a very, very pleasant taste
and the young tender leaves themselves,
if you slice them up,
they're a very pleasant vegetable, very nutritious.
- You've often mentioned the idea that even for animals
and like dogs, which are carnivores,
that too much meat without enough calcium is an issue.
Same for people, right?
Dogs, too much meat and we need more calcium
than real calcium with bones or?
- Yeah, in the wild, animals tend to eat the small bones
like a carnivore eats a chicken.
They aren't gonna spit out many of the bones
because they can crush them and get the marrow out
and so on, so they're getting lots of calcium
in their normal diet.
- Interesting and the calcium then,
that ratio you suggested affects the thyroid, right?
Can make the thyroid not work as well.
- Well, that's a consequence but the first thing
is the parathyroid hormone increases
under the influence of too much phosphate
or not enough calcium and the parathyroid hormone
is what turns on the activated vitamin D,
the harmful part of the vitamin D system
and it turns off cellular energy production.
Not only in the hair follicle but in the thyroid gland
and muscles, everything gets weak and tends to get inflamed
if you have too much parathyroid hormone
and phosphate is the main thing in excess
that will drive your parathyroid hormone too high.
- Interesting, there's a lot of very natural breeders
that have been using the whole chicken raw for dogs
for a long time and they do very well on it
'cause I guess they're eating all the bones, too.
- Yep.
- Dear Dr. Peat, this is Susan in Tennessee.
Is glycerin okay to use topically, glycerin topically?
- Yeah, I think it is okay topically.
You don't want to take it orally
because part of the effect of stress
is to release fat from storage
and every molecule of triglyceride
involves a glycerin molecule.
And glycerin, even from our natural tissue stores,
a certain amount of it converts to methylglyoxal
which is a toxin and which adds to the protein glycation
and the aging process.
So you definitely don't want to ingest glycerin.
I wouldn't use it copiously on the skin
because a little bit of it might get absorbed.
- We're talking with Dr. Ray Peat.
He's here on the third Monday of the month,
One Radio Network.
You can check out other videos we've done with Dr. Peat
on One Radio Network.
Look for the video section and also in the archives,
all the audio shows are there.
His website is RayPeat.com
and you can send him an email,
Ray Peat's—plural—newsletter@gmail.com
and sign up for his terrific newsletter.
It comes out every couple of months.
Dr. Peat, do you have much experience
with using for different things, DMSO?
- Oh yeah.
- Do you?
- I was very interested in it in the mid, late 60s
and then I had a series of experiences
in which it was producing inflammation
and that sort of discouraged my interest in it.
Besides, it produces a bad taste in your mouth
if you just get it on your skin
and it can easily take impurities into your skin with it
and so the question of getting an absolutely pure substance
in itself is hard enough,
but then if you just introduce a trace of contaminant
along with it, it can--
- Drive it right in.
- Penetrate, yeah.
- I mean, you could actually,
people have said you could use some maybe DMSO
and something else on your feet and put on a sock
and if it has dye in there, that would draw that in.
You have to be careful with that stuff.
I did a sauna, I like to do a sauna
with a little bit of DMSO and castor oil
and just let it on my stomach
and I did one the other night and I just got over,
I don't know, overabundant with the DMSO
and Dr. Peat, I have to tell you,
my stomach burned on the outside.
I actually burnt it for about two or three days.
I mean, it's been itching and it's finally going away.
That stuff can burn you, right?
- I was seeing that happen frequently around 1970
so I lost interest in using it.
- I have to be careful with this stuff.
Here's an email from Trent.
If low cell oxygen can result in cancer,
will antioxidants such as vitamin E or vitamin C
promote the growth of cancer?
- Actually, cancer produces its own powerful
reductants and antioxidants
and the big change that has been happening
in the last 10 years is realizing
that vitamin C, when it's working in a healthy cell,
is a pro-oxidant.
The reductant antioxidant form of it
is not what's doing most of the benefit.
It's the catalytic support of the oxidative systems
that makes vitamin C useful.
And vitamin E has its oxidative phase.
And the things you find in orange juice,
fruits and vegetables, the polyphenols,
nobiletin, fisetin, for example,
these have been historically classified as antioxidants
but actually they shift the cell pro-oxidative processes,
protect against the excess reduction,
the opposite of oxidation that goes with stress
and that is characteristic of cancer.
The cancer metabolism is stuck
in an over-reductive antioxidant condition.
- Here's an email from Ellen.
Interesting, my sister chose to do chemotherapy
for cancer and she's incredibly nauseous,
can barely eat any kind of food.
Can you recommend some kind of foods or drinks
that I could share with her
so she could get something down?
- Moderately salty chicken broth
is historically one of the best things.
The broth is a complex mixture
that doesn't do anything irritating
but it has to be moderately salted
because if there's too much water,
that in itself creates inflammation
in the digestive system.
So the natural fluids,
the right concentration of a salted broth
or milk or orange juice,
which are more or less balanced solutions,
those are all supportive of healing
and anti-inflammatory,
promote oxidative healing processes.
- I see.
And so these chemicals,
do they damage the mucosa of the stomach
and cause nausea or what's going on?
- Yeah, chemotherapy is killing cells
in proportion to how fast they grow
and your stomach lining is probably the fastest growing
other than parts of your immune system.
The stomach lining is turning over
every two days roughly.
And so if you kill the fast growing cells,
that's how a lethal dose of ionizing radiation,
for example, kills people by burning out
the lining of their stomach,
of their intestine.
The chemical therapy does the same thing.
It kills cells in proportion
to how fast they're replicating,
assuming that cancer is always fast growing.
But very often a tumor is slow growing
but still determined to go down the wrong pathway
even though it isn't dividing very fast.
So the ordinary radiation and chemotherapy
are going to hurt your intestinal cells
much more than they hurt the cancer
if it's slow growing.
- On the vitamin C,
do I recall that you're not a big fan
of using just ascorbic acid or sodium ascorbate?
- Yeah, because of that reduction.
It's a powerful reductant.
And what you wanna do is get it into your cells
in an oxidized form without pushing
the growth of cancer cells, for example,
or starting a process of inflammation.
Once it gets into the cells,
about 80% of vitamin C is in the form of dehydroascorbate.
And that means that eating meat,
the animal's vitamin C that it makes
is in all of its tissues, including the muscles,
and at least 70 to 85% of it will be
in the invisible oxidized form, DHA.
And so when you're eating meat,
you're taking in lots of vitamin C.
And still, the official Department of Agriculture charts
don't show any vitamin C content for meat,
even though Amundsen, was that his name,
the Arctic Explorer, showed that they did fine
if they ate meat all winter, didn't get scurvy.
- How many oranges would we need a day
to get plenty of vitamin C?
- So the anti-scurvy dose is only about one orange a day.
- One orange?
- Is enough, but for general health,
it's fine to eat 20 a day.
- You can eat a lot of oranges.
Is there a benefit to eating the whole orange
rather than juicing it?
- Not if it's a commercially grown orange,
because the toxins pretty much stick on the peel,
and so you don't want to make marmalade
out of anything but a clean, organic orange.
- But organic orange, you eat the whole thing,
is it more beneficial than juicing?
- Well, when you cook it in a marmalade,
it is very beneficial, but once I heard that
when I was about 16 or 17,
and tried eating a whole orange,
and it's very irritating to the stomach.
I couldn't keep it down.
- Fascinating how cooking some things
really make them more powerful.
- Yeah, it releases the actually valuable nutrients
and degrades some of the irritants.
- That would be true in things like kale, collards?
- Oh yeah, the--
- Cauliflower?
- Yeah, leaves are very full of irritants
intended to interfere with animals' digestion,
aimed primarily at worms and herbivores,
but when we eat them, they have specific enzyme inhibitors
that will decrease the nutritional value.
But when you cook it, some of those are degraded,
and so it's a lot safer to eat well-cooked vegetables.
- Kale's a good food, kale?
- Yeah, as a source of vitamin K in particular,
calcium, magnesium.
- Would you ask Dr. Peat, this is from Helen in Australia,
approach to dealing with uterine fibroids,
especially when they have grown so much
that they're putting pressure on the colon and my bladder.
Wow, okay.
- Yeah, having a blood test is important
to check your thyroid, estrogen, and vitamin D.
Calcium and vitamin D are recognized
as very important anti-fibroid factors,
along with thyroid.
One outstanding example, I think,
illustrates what thyroid can do.
A woman in her early 40s hadn't had a child and wanted to,
but she had a big fibroid blocking the top of her uterus,
blocking both fallopian tubes.
I explained how thyroid lowers estrogen
while increasing the activity of enzymes
that can break down fibrotic tissue.
Anyway, she took what her doctor said
was a very dangerous overdose of thyroid,
kept her heart rate beating at rest, 110 beats per minute.
That was in the spring.
She had an ultrasound every month
and saw visible shrinking,
so she stayed with it through the summer.
And by, I think it was September or October,
she was pregnant.
The tumor had shrunken visibly every month
just by keeping her estrogen under control,
by keeping a steadily,
slightly above average thyroid activity.
- Interesting.
How's azithromycin—how do you say that?
A-Z-I-T-H—safe? Dan wants to know.
- What about it?
- Is it safe to take?
- Oh, I think it is.
I've used erythromycin, which is the original form.
They're very similar.
They both have the extra virtue
of being anti-inflammatory
and somewhat pro-propulsion of the intestine.
So people who are having intestinal problems
notice that the inflammation goes down
and the tendency to reverse peristalsis
or reflux during the night or constipation,
the erythromycin acts as a mild laxative
keeping the intestine going in the right direction
rather than coming up into the throat.
- And why does it go,
what's the causes of it coming back the other way
and causing heartburn and other stuff?
- During the night, excitation increases
from the blood sugar going down
and this generalized inflammation
against a background of low thyroid,
the thyroid keeps the peristalsis
running in the normal direction from top to bottom.
When that gets confused
and you get random centers of irritation and inflammation,
inflammation just below your stomach, for example,
can start a wave of peristalsis moving through your stomach
and up your esophagus,
carrying stomach contents
or even lower intestinal contents into your mouth.
A medical professor in the 1920s
experimented on his medical students
putting an indicator, an indigestible particle
that is very easy to recognize under the microscope.
He put a little dollop of this
in the rectums of all of his medical students
and then in the morning had them take a swab of saliva
and put it under the microscope
and all of those who had morning breath
found the particles that had been inserted the night before.
- Whoa.
- Showing that reverse peristalsis,
even in healthy young people, is very common
and it shows up most often
as simply bad breath in the morning.
- Reverse peristalsis, go figure.
Here's someone that's chronically underweight, they say,
despite eating high calorie foods
filled with carbohydrates, fats, and protein.
And I'm experiencing low thyroid,
so could the related low thyroid be the cause of this?
- Yeah, over the years I've talked to,
I think three or four young middle-aged men,
20s and 30s, early 40s,
who were eating maybe 4,000 calories a day
and still weighed only 135 or 145 pounds,
just couldn't put on any muscle.
And my own experience was that
through my late teens and 20s,
I ate gigantic amounts,
produced huge amounts of heat and steam,
but stayed at the same weight,
165 or 170.
And as soon as I experimented taking thyroid,
my caloric requirement decreased by 30 or 40%
and I suddenly was able to put on weight.
And so I mentioned thyroid supplements to these men.
Each one of them had the same experience.
Immediately they were able to put on weight.
That's because thyroid is our basic anabolic hormone.
That was published in endocrine textbooks 80 years ago.
A picture of people who had experienced removal
of their thyroid gland without replacement
of a thyroid supplement.
They wasted away, it was called the cachexia,
the wasting disease caused by thyroid deprivation.
- I mentioned to you in an email,
I was gonna try the Cynoplus,
my TSH is up a little,
and I ordered it from Mexico
and it ended up with the FDA in Chicago
and it's held in ransom.
It's a shame that they've done that.
Maybe it's just a one-off thing, I hope.
Have you heard anybody else of that happening too?
- Um, just occasionally.
- Okay, it was probably just a bad karma for Patrick.
- I think it's like a lottery.
- Yeah, it's like a lottery.
You just take your, pays your money, you take your chances.
Few more here.
Oh Stella, this is interesting.
Could you please ask Dr. Peat,
I'm in my 20s, struggling with self-pleasuring
for five years since been with someone,
wondering what I can do to control
sexual urges and desires.
I'm suffering.
Wow, interesting.
- Having hormone tests as part of it,
the ability to get satisfaction
is an essential part of the sexual response.
Arousal is a big part, but satisfaction is the end of it.
And that thyroid and related hormones
are essential parts of that.
- So if the thyroid is out of balance,
that can make other things be out of balance.
- Yeah, the estrogen goes up in relation
to progesterone and the androgens.
And estrogen is the gadfly that creates arousal,
but progesterone and the androgen and thyroid
are the things that create the energy process
that gives satisfaction.
- I see, interesting.
Hi Dr. Peat, I love your newsletter, thank you.
You're turning me into a PhD.
My question is, can you talk about the symptoms
of shingles, how to address these symptoms
and how to keep this virus, in quotes,
is it a virus, he says dormant, thank you.
- A good non-inflammatory diet is the first thing,
but aspirin is the most generally useful drug
for turning off the herpes virus in particular.
When you get your nutrition up and use aspirin regularly,
that will quiet the nerves that are creating
the excitement that causes the virus to replicate.
- So this little guy gets in there, this herpes virus,
and it never kind of goes away
and just comes alive sometimes?
- Yeah, the nucleic acid of it lives in the cell body
and only when the organism is under stress,
when the pituitary is activated by a change of season,
for example, this activates the virus
to travel down the nerve fiber into the skin
where it produces the sore and becomes infectious.
And at that point, probably an ointment
or a wash containing dissolved aspirin
will help at the surface,
but the quieting anti-inflammatory effect
of aspirin systemically reduces that continuing process.
So keeping your energy up with good food and thyroid
supplemented with aspirin as needed
is the quickest way to bring a shingles attack to a close.
- Yeah, so I guess that would explain,
and you hear stories over the years of brides
who are so excited that they show up
on their wedding day with a cold sore, right?
I mean, it kind of makes sense sometimes.
- Yeah, yeah, emotional nervous excitement
is a major thing.
- Mike wants to know what a holiday dinner feast
looks like at the Dr. Peat's household.
- Oh, very simple.
- Very simple?
- Often just a fine stew.
- Make a stew or something?
- Mm-hmm.
- Yeah, yeah.
Couple more here.
Let's see.
Thanks for listening to Dr. Peat for a long time.
I'm glad you have him on.
Can you ask his thoughts,
is there any connection to Lyme disease
and anything he would recommend for someone
with Lyme and ALS?
- ALS?
- ALS, yes, and Lyme's connection.
- Oh, well, ALS is the degenerative nerve disease, right?
Lou Gehrig's disease. - I believe so, yeah.
Lou Gehrig's, yeah.
- Lyme disease is definitely a bacterial
spirochete-type infection,
and it can be cured two or three weeks,
maybe using two or three antibiotics at the same time,
but there are some doctors that claim
that it's a perpetual thing that takes endless treatment,
but really it's very cleanly eradicated
by a good course of antibiotics.
I've had experience only with one person
with confirmed ALS,
and he started changing his diet and behavior
right at the very beginning,
and he met a lot of other patients at the same stage
in the neurologist's office,
and so he watched the course of their disease
very similar to his for the first few months,
but then suddenly he started getting better
as they kept getting worse,
and all he was doing was changing his hormones
and nutrients, the things that we've been talking about,
but also every day he would shine a bright light
on the back of his neck in particular
for an hour or more every day,
making sure he was getting penetrating light
into his nervous system,
as well as doing all of the anti-inflammatory,
pro-energetic things,
and he had reached a point where he bought equipment
for using the bathroom, hoists,
and all of that sort of equipment,
and quit his job at his own business,
and was ready basically to become a complete invalid,
but then suddenly his improvement started,
and in less than a year from the time he started,
he was completely recovered,
sold all of his machinery,
and went back to work.
- I'll be, I'll be.
- At the age of 70 or 71.
- That's fascinating.
Do you think exposure to red light
and the various lights that are available ongoing
is a benefit for the body?
- I think a plain, like a--
- Chicken lamp?
- Chicken lamp, plain clear front light bulb is good.
It has all of the spectrum,
and we aren't sure exactly which wavelengths
are the therapeutic ones.
Red definitely is part of it,
but I think it's good to have orange and yellow
at the same time.
- And those chicken lamps,
I think you can actually get at Home Depot, right?
And you just put 'em in there, 10 bucks?
- Five dollars, they should be.
- Is anyone doing, here's an interesting one,
is anyone doing, Dr. Peat,
the William Budd maintenance method
for type one diabetes today?
The urine must be measured to match the glucose
going into the glucose going out, doesn't it?
- Well, it spontaneously does that.
The more sugar you eat, the more will come out,
except that, yeah, if you do that,
that will reduce the consumption of your good tissues,
converting them to sugar.
So if you eat as much as you're losing,
that will tend to cure the process.
It stops the stress, which is destroying your pancreas.
And I've only known a few people
who decided to get off the program
and start eating a balanced high-carbohydrate diet,
and they had the same experience
that those doctors did 140 years ago.
- George says, "I'm experimenting with thyroid medicine
"I did get from Mexico."
Patrick, oh, okay.
And my TSH is about four,
and I'm wondering how I could determine
at the right dosage if I was getting too much.
What would be some signs that I'm taking too much?
- Overheating is the first thing.
- Overheating, meaning taking your temperature
first thing in the morning?
- No, just feeling too hot, out of breath,
and then checking your temperature.
Your temperature might get to 99 all day,
but if your pulse rate is going 120 at rest,
that's definitely too much.
So you should aim for a daytime 98.6
and 80 to 85 pulse rate.
- Wow.
So 80 to 85 is normal for a thyroid normal person.
- Yeah, for a very metabolically active person
who's burning calories intensely.
- And it's higher even for girls, the pulse?
- And the what?
- And it's higher even for women, the pulse rate?
- Roughly, yeah.
- A little bit?
Wow.
- Women have smaller hearts,
so they beat faster for pumping the same amount of blood.
- I didn't know that.
Women have smaller hearts.
I think we just, two more.
So, can I use niacin on my left leg only
to improve circulation in that leg,
and foot, which has gotten pretty bad with MS,
I would have to take it internally?
Oh, niacin.
- I think generally niacinamide internally is the safest
because big doses of nicotinic acid
create increased prostaglandins
and have a lot of pro-inflammatory things
that I don't think are at all good for MS.
- So niacinamide, does that in general
increase circulation?
Does it do the flushing thing?
- It improves metabolism.
- Metabolism.
- By reducing free fatty acids that block oxidation.
- Leon is in San Diego.
I experience bloating one to two hours
after my evening meal.
I've done a food list and journal,
and it doesn't seem to be associated with any food.
It happens with all food.
I'm wondering if Dr. Peat thinks
I could be having not enough acid
or not enough enzymes or both.
- Yeah, and the peristalsis might be a problem too.
So having some fiber in the diet
is one way of reducing inflammation
and stimulating peristalsis.
And then checking your body temperature.
Usually a low body temperature
goes with sluggish peristalsis.
- I see, and so that could be causing his problems,
the bloat, because the peristalsis is just happening.
- Yeah, the stomach and the intestine just sit there
letting any gas that forms stay put and blow up,
where peristalsis should be squeezing out
little bits of gas as they form.
- I see, and then that would be,
different forms of fiber would be the psyllium husks maybe,
and mushrooms?
- Yeah, mushrooms are very pleasant.
Psyllium husks constipate a few people,
but when they work, they're fine.
Cooked bamboo shoots are good for some people.
Oat bran mush works all right, but it's very starchy.
- Wow, so you keep that going and that causes things
to not back up like he's getting.
So that's the bloating.
It's just not moving downward.
Let's see.
I think we have one more.
Please mention what a chicken lamp is.
What's a chicken, oh, these are chicken lamps
where you can get at Home Depot, right, Doc?
And they're the big silver thing that you can put 'em in
with a clamp.
You've seen those, you can find 'em
in the electrical department.
And a chicken lamp is go to the light department
at the Home Depot and they have these red,
I guess, are they LED or, near-red, aren't they lamps?
- Well, they're usually clear front.
The clear front is a lot cheaper.
- Oh.
- And it has just as much red light.
- Really, so you don't even need the red front.
- No, the red front cuts out blue light,
so gives a red appearance, but the clear front
is putting out just as much red radiation.
- But isn't the blue light an issue
for turning off melatonin, or is it different blue light
from the computer and a television screen?
- Well, the good thing about the chicken lamp
is there's very little blue in it.
- Okay.
- Because it runs warmer, less hot.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, Dr. Peat, good job.
We kept you a long time.
Thanks for hanging with us.
Happy holidays, Merry Christmas to you.
And we will see you, I guess, in the third week in January.
And so have fun and stay out of trouble.
And appreciate you being here once a month.
It's really an honor, sir.
- Oh, okay, very good, thank you.
- Thank you, sir.
Dr. Ray Peat, Patrick Timpone, oneradionetwork.com.
Well, we are going to take some time off here.
It is December 21st, the summer, the winter solstice,
all kinds of things.
Pluto is getting together with Saturn
and all kinds of fun things are happening.
Goodness knows, the astrological people
are just all kind of a-twitter this time of the year,
some of the things that are going on
with the winter solstice.
And tonight, a couple hours after sunset,
wherever you are, you can go on there
and see the whole, the planets doing their little thing.
Saturn and, is it Saturn and, yeah, here they are.
It's kind of fun.
Well, Saturn and Jupiter, they're like the closest
they've been in since 1226.
Hello, that's a long time, closest they've been.
So the astrological people say some pretty exciting things
are gonna be happening on planet Earth.
Things get turned upside down and turned over
and if one kind of wants to morph these ideas
into the struggle that's going on in our culture
to save our republic, and that's what I believe this is.
This is not about Donald Trump and Joe Biden,
much bigger deal.
This is a real, a real third act of a movie
and it is, in my opinion, a struggle for our republic
to save this country from going the way of a globalist
who wanna change the whole deal.
And this is what it's about and it's a big deal.
You can go on our Parler page
and we talk about it a little bit,
but there's a lot of people talking about it.
You don't need us, but just keep in touch with us
during this end of the year.
I'll be in touch on email.
If we can do anything for you, please let us know.
I'll be around and we'll see you back
on the beginning of January.
But so who knows what's gonna be going on
between now and then and then after January.
And so we're gonna see.
We'll see what's going on.
Lots and lots of very exciting things.
You might, this is an interesting story that is out today.
President Trump is out today saying
we are closer and closer than ever to
succeeding in our second term.
So he's got something going on that's way above and beyond
what we're being told the possibilities are.
But we've been writing about it.
You'll see him on our Parler thing and you'll see him,
now I guess we'll go on MeWe and do that.
But we've done some shows on that,
but you do your research and kinda keep in touch
and we'll see what happens.
Could be a whole brave new world
by the time we get together.
I guess it'll be January 4th, right, with Adam Bergstrom.
So one last little plug for Surthrival.
There's a 21%, 21% sale going on right now
if you're listening live on this 21 December 2020.
Use promo code infinite today only.
I guess it's just until midnight tonight.
21% on all Surthrival products.
That would be the Chaga, the Reishi, the Pine Pollen,
Elk Velvet Antler, the Vitamin D-K2 thing,
the Digestive Bitters, which we like a lot,
Colostrum, I guess that's about it.
Lot of great products.
Elk Velvet Antler, Pine Pollen.
Surthrival promo code infinite.
Tonight only, today only, celebrating the 21st,
the winter solstice, 21% off, promo code infinite.
Okay, so we're out of here.
We will see you live back on the 4th of January
with Adam Bergstrom.
We have all of our videos now being laid out on our website.
You don't need to go to YouTube or anywhere else.
If you'd like to watch the videos of these people,
oneradionetwork.com, you'll see the videos.
They're all being propagated there.
We've no longer doing the Facebook thing.
And we're on Parler and MeWe,
and we can keep in touch there.
This is mostly the MeWe for you all,
you all, we say that in Texas,
for you all to communicate with one another.
You don't need me.
And you can, you know, talk amongst yourself
and just be kind and don't get snarky on MeWe.
But at least they're a free platform
and there's no censorship going on on MeWe
that we know of, as well as Parler.
We're just tired of YouTube and Facebook,
and they really are just not very good people
censoring just everything.
So, goodness knows what their karma dharma is,
but we don't want any part of them.
So we're just blowing the popsicle stand.
It's over.
Sorry, Mark, we are breaking up, Mr. Zuck.
Godspeed.
So I love you all very much.
Thank you for everything.
It's been an honor to be here.
It's been quite a year.
This is a wrap for 2020.
We've all been through quite a bit,
just depending on how much of the movie
that we bought into during the year.
And we've all bought into a little bit of it.
So, but we've made it through.
We're stronger than we ever were.
Stronger than we ever were.
Or whatever.
I think we have a note here from Adam.
Oh, Adam wants to be friends on MeWe.
Yeah, I'll do that, okay.
(laughs)
Adam has a MeWe thing.
Visit with Adam on MeWe as well.
Remember, 20 years ago, Zuckerberg started like a MeWe.
I think we have 75 friends or something.
Doesn't matter.
All right, kids, have fun.
Take care of yourself.
I love you.
May the blessings be.
Take care.
(upbeat music)
Nothing is more expensive than bad information.
Know the source, oneradionetwork.com.
(upbeat music)
[BLANK_AUDIO]